what what do you think of as a problem  for the in the ordinary Big Bang  boundary proposals what do you think of  it as a problem is it a problem where  people start talking about problems in  areas where the physics really isn't  well defined what I say is well okay  that's fine let's talk about the physics  where we can understand it in my book um  Adam which was a history of an atom from  the beginning of the universe to the end  what am I actually one of my favorite  books I think it's useful to begin our  history of the universe to back to a  time when both our theories and our  empirical data allow us to reliably  extrapolate before that it's just pure  speculation I'm sure we can talk about  it but it's just words